we're headed to go meet up with my dad
who I haven't seen in about eight years
I wish I had a very clear sign of why we
didn't talk or what happened like there
was never a big blowup we just stopped
talking that's probably the most painful
part of it
apparently I I wasn't enough for my dad
to stay around I remember being so
nervous yesterday that he wasn't gonna
show up I mean I bought a plane ticket
arrange all of this and I still was
sitting there yesterday like he's not
gonna come it's just weird to have a
person who is so deeply connected to me
feel so distant at the same time he
would promise to show up and he would
say he would do things and then wouldn't
come or just like wouldn't call me back
or just would disappear like I feel like
I should know this man and to be honest
he should truly just a stranger I don't
know that we will leave this
conversation being this happy
father-and-son I don't know that we will
ever have a real relationship but the
worst-case scenario is more of the same
it just feels it feels more real and
more real than I thought it was gonna
feel and I just am nervous I don't I
don't know why I don't feel like I have
a reason to be nervous but it just feels
very nerve-racking
my dad has been in and out of my life
mostly out he's not a bad person he just
wasn't the best dad I've moved on like I
don't hold a lot of anger or resentment
towards him about it it's a conversation
I want to have and just kind of get to
know him because I feel like I missed
out on getting to know him one specific
memory I have that was just us building
like a fort of Lee's we were at my
grandmother's house we hung out all day
like so long that we got locked out of
my grandmother's house because something
like my grandmother left and we were
just like hanging out and that's most of
my memories with my dad if like the
older I got the less time I spent with
him the middle of the day for me is to
find some level of closure and kind of
get to know myself better by getting to
know my dad and getting to know some of
the pain I went through you okay yeah
fine
I don't just I just I know hello I'm
you're nervous yeah I am happy to see
you you look good I wish I don't put on
some weight but yeah
the older I get think cuz I know I would
through Pierre where I was like very
angry with you
I'm sure and you have every right to be
yeah every right to be that's why when
this can you call I cry right now
cry for a minute because there's like
I've been praying to God about it and I
got I got a family had to come first
home and I took me a while to get that
54 years to get that but I got for me I
thought there's just a lot it was a lot
to unpack like in order for me to like
grow as a person in like be a better
person I have to like just talk to you
about just stuff just starting like what
like what do you think a bit like I
guess a good dad is don't think again a
good dad is someone that you could count
on someone just there you have to be
there and it's funny when you say that
because you know as a kid growing up you
know grandpa you know I see growing up
with him being the way he was I said I
always said I was gonna be a better day
and turned out getting caught up in the
other things right I think that like
pain becomes more real the older you get
it does and it's it would have been nice
to have you there I feel like it just
it's just like real it would have been
nice to have but you want to answer for
that right not necessarily the answer
that's what I like and I'm ready for you
not to have a direct the answer like cuz
if I don't know I get it no it's not
gonna say I don't know but all I could
tell you they're gonna be excuses right
that's all y'all I messed up I wasn't a
good father to you guys I wasn't I
should have been there I missed a lot
and I can't get that back and that
that's something I have to live with for
the rest of my life I was smoking the
ones I was doing all kind of things and
you I wasn't I wasn't in the right place
for you guys I think that you graduating
college either I can't get that back
right that hurts
there's a lot but it's a small ball I'm
not trying to make excuses for anything
like growing up I felt like because
Cameron is a little bit he's a little
more like sensitive to your relationship
and like I think he shows his emotions
more and then mom was always working and
like a lot of times I felt like I had to
be the happy one it wasn't you it had
not only tuna throwing I'm saying it's
just that it doesn't hurt because I had
to be strong Abby for everybody because
camera didn't believe in you and so I
had to be like no dad come through this
time and mom didn't believe in you and I
had a big dream it felt like and even to
this day it's hard for me then to be
vulnerable people and not put on a happy
face all the time
like I've never had I'm sorry I feel
like I've never had someone to be there
it would have been nice to have dad just
look like allowed him to be sad you're
right
I wish I could change that I really
effective do anything to change my words
but I can't and I get that I'm not
this isn't me like attacking or like I
don't think what you didn't even if you
did I deserved it if you did I deserve
that
there's a lot of times I wanted to just
get up and just pop up and find you find
out where you were but I just didn't
want to I just didn't want to mess up
your life man that's the truth
I can't make you happy or come talk to
you about something if I don't have me
right I had to get me right before I
could do anything and I did that therapy
Hey
drugs and I've been through it all now
I'm here we started talking about it
earlier I'd know cuz I got never I
having like a that told you I guess in
person before I believed you but like I
have not come out to you I guess yeah
yeah so yeah like I am gay and I didn't
like I assumed you knew because I knew
you follow me on like social media just
that bother you know doesn't that bother
me at all I feel I don't feel upset
about I feel as long as he's happy and
he's living the life the way he wants to
live he still I love him he's my son
I know specifically in the black
community and like I would remember one
of the things that happen with mom when
I told her she is just like scared for
me and I didn't know if that was ever
like yes that's part of one of the
reasons why worried about you down here
in LA by yourself like you will be the
place to be but I don't I don't look at
it like that I look at my son's down
here in a new place no no you got a few
family people down here but he's in a
new place and it's just a crazy world we
live in around this is a dis world we
live in today it's not the same things
are things are different and people
try to hurt people just because of who
they are and the way they are you
remember all right mm-hmm
so okay her son I did not realize this
when I was younger but the older I got I
realized that he molested me as a kid
and I what okay I know that it's like
but like that's like I don't know how to
bring this up but I feel like that
something I feel like you should know I
don't think that one know that I do not
blame you in any way shape or form cuz
you didn't know he would have had no way
to know cuz I didn't even know now as an
adult looking back I understand that it
was him being inappropriate I don't
think I knew what it was as a kid he
didn't know where was the kids you're
supposed to say with dad
I didn't but I didn't I didn't know what
was wrong I how I didn't like he was
just like kind of make me touch him and
I did it and I didn't know I don't know
how I feel about it really but I just
felt like it was so much it just like to
let you know yeah just I'm glad you did
that's another example of what I'm
saying about me in my life I've now I'm
feeling bad like I put you in a position
or in a situation is you shouldn't have
been here those are the things that I
learned and I think about certain I put
myself in certain situations and I feel
like some of the situation's I put
myself in and some of the things I did I
consider it affected my entire life and
it took to my family it's affected you
which affected Cameron I haven't I
haven't felt like I needed a shot or
anything else I know here's what that
was something I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry for that too well that shouldn't
have happened
I'm glad because you can come out you
can tell me things now I'm hoping this
is a start
today went a lot better that I thought
it would
how did you speak to see well what I
didn't know you were gonna show up yeah
okay I don't know I didn't know what to
expect but like I think unfortunately I
had just gotten so used to expecting the
worse mm-hmm I actually just feel like
it went way better no no I'm just I'm
glad we got to talk I'm glad with you to
hope this is the beginning of something
totally new how did you don't hate me no
life is too short to hate regardless of
what we went through or what our
relationship was last year's I wouldn't
exist without you and I find it very
hard to hate someone who for better or
worse made me who I am so one of the
reasons I wanted to like finish out
nature was just like because one of like
my fondest memories yeah it's with you
it's like when we were playing Italy you
know getting locked out so it was just
cool to kind of like I don't know full
circle come back to later yeah
I like I hated the fact that I really
didn't have a picture of us together
like it will be cool to like kind of
take a picture and his know it sounds
cheesy no it's not cheesy no I want a
decent picture with my dad a decent
picture this will be good I'm balding
now too so thanks for that
well that's gonna happen ready yeah good
see I know isn't it to me all right
I don't know what your phone be able to
like soon as you my email no my phone
won't be
[Music]
[Music]
hey unsub is on a new channel and now
you're part subscribe here that was my
part